une scène de crime un mort et un suspect
a recherché voilà comment débute la
murder party à la villa eugénie
dezauzier locaux de l'office de tourisme
de saint germain en laye une enquête
palpitante
à découvrir en famille la volonté
d'organiser de murder party à l'aîné en
fait en la première qu'on a fait elle
est en 2018
nous mêmes
venez devenir office de tourisme
intercommunal on venait d'emménager dans
des nouveaux locaux et c'était
l'occasion de surfer un peu sur cette
vague d murder dévoila de pouvoir
proposer bah finalement une
une activité interactive qui est adapté
aussi bien aux adultes qu'aux enfants
cette soirée interactive spécial
halloween s'organise sur deux étages le
public part à la recherche d'énigmes et
d' indices pour retrouver là où le
coupable une sorte de credo grandeur
nature le principe c'est qu'un meurtre a
été commis en 1908 au sein de la demeure
des des loyers qui laquelle l'office du
tourisme en fait qu'ils aient leur
ancienne demeure et il le public doit se
mettre dans la peau d'un d'enquêtrice et
d'enquêteur et pouvoir résoudre cette
affaire en une heure la murder party est
organisée samedi 30 octobre et compte
trois créneaux le premier est à 17
heures à peu près où on a peut-être
avancer à 16h45 a pris en à un vers 18
heures et le dernier vers 19h30 le but
cela c'est une spéciale halloween donc
c'était quand même d'avoir un peu
l'effet nocturne de nuit réservation
obligatoire le public est invité à se
déguiser pour l'événement sur saint
germain en laye les commerçants
proposent également une chasse au trésor
samedi 30 octobre après midi